foreign
podcast special guest in here Atlanta
Georgia's Own the homie Kenny Mason is
here we're going on my boy welcome man
welcome sir yo uh I you know I gotta set
your [ __ ] and man you're fired bro
like I was very impressed appreciate it
yeah um talk about like uh just kind of
give me some of your background for
people who don't know who you are you
got an album out right now that's crazy
and uh yo you can wrap your ass off but
give us some of your background like how
long you've been making music and you
know where you from and all that what
yeah like he said I'm from Atlanta
Georgia
um from the west side
the southwest side
and uh I've been making music since I
was probably like I've been trying to
rap so I would probably like
12 13 but I feel like I became like an
artist I understood what it mean to be
an artist right probably like 19 like
right after I graduated high school how
old are you now I'm 26. okay for sure so
yeah so you've been doing this for a
while then yeah yeah folk think I'm like
still 19 years yeah you still you look
like you're about 19. you could have
told me I'm 19 I would have been like
yeah yeah that's cool yeah yeah so um
when you say you figured out what it
meant to be an artist you know some
people who watching this might not
understand that because I feel like
anybody can rap or you know
put some words together make a song but
like to really like
find your purpose and you know what
separates you from the rest it's like
like what do you mean by that yeah
exactly that like finally finding your
voice what you what you put on here what
you put on Earth to say or to do for
people other than just you know saying
saying words flipping words like
uh you know like
you can be athletic you know what I'm
saying but like knowing your position
though like the best position you play
on teams is like what's important could
that how you win the game that's some
real [ __ ] hey Anthony Davis was a point
guard what the [ __ ] yeah in high school
that fool was playing point guard that's
crazy and now he's a center
that's wild to think that that big ass
[ __ ] was playing poison who the
[ __ ] what coach made that decision
that's why he's so good though because
he could run the point yeah he's fast
the [ __ ] like a yeah damn yeah yeah [ __ ]
that's hard so coming from Atlanta like
you know I feel like lyrically your
um
very very uh poignant like like and
obviously some of the best rappers ever
are are from your city shout out to
Outcast Killer Mike you know tip guys
like that like who were some of your
influences though like coming up man
that kind of formed your style that
aren't they don't even have to be from
Atlanta
um
I feel like I started rapping because I
was listening to Lil Wayne okay you know
what I'm saying like just trying to beat
him
I was like 13 12 13. just drive of
course
do that [ __ ] he did and that's what got
me like doing it but like
um I feel like
on some Atlanta [ __ ] I used to
I used to play we played a lot of rich
kids okay all the time you know who that
is I heard of him before yeah they like
Atlanta Legends yeah now I've heard of
them I never really like tapped in like
that but I'm like I know that they're
big in in the city out there so I feel
like they slept though or they they like
shaped the sound for like
they shaped a lot of sound for Atlanta
and then thus shaping a lot of sound for
the world because Atlanta Shake A lot of
times I think a lot of people in Atlanta
like you know I always think about like
the SoundCloud era
and I always remember the first artist I
heard
we're all from Atlanta like father like
there was like a bunch of guys like out
there in Atlanta that I felt like really
kind of popped the SoundCloud [ __ ] off
and then the rest of the world kind of
ran with it yeah I feel like no Folk
like probably like
that era of Atlanta
oh I'm biased too so [ __ ] Gonna get
mad but I feel like that [ __ ] kind of
invented SoundCloud or like that type of
I think so for sure yeah because I
remember those were the first times I'd
ever see people like on it like like I
go on like two dopeboys.com and like
there'd be SoundCloud links and [ __ ] and
it'd be like yeah a couple of folks
people were just dropping mixtapes like
or they were on like Z share or like
random ass like media fire you remember
that [ __ ] yeah yeah and then there's
like oh [ __ ] this SoundCloud [ __ ] is
kind of hard it's lightning I I ain't
even gotta try to download [ __ ] no more
exactly you just stream it yeah for show
for show so your album uh you know you
got one of my close friends on there
Freddie Gibbs yeah uh who's and you know
one of the in my opinion one of the
greatest of all time
um how did that happen
uh I ain't even know like I think my
folks like just sent his folks a song I
hadn't met him in there like that you
still haven't met him yet no I still
ain't mad really yeah DM he showed love
and [ __ ] oh DMS and [ __ ] but I ain't met
him in real life yet now oh [ __ ] I ain't
been nowhere bro like I ain't seen the
pandemic like we dropped both of them
both of the projects right in the
pandemic I ain't been nowhere just being
in the house we did both of them in the
house so you recorded both at the crib
dropped them both during the pandemic
and [ __ ] ain't been nowhere well that's
I went to Tennessee for like a month but
it's still I missed right there yeah
what part of Tennessee did you go to
who's in Nashville okay yeah but we
still didn't go nowhere it was just like
it's not a bad Drive what's that happen
what's that like six hours
yeah I mean we were in Atlanta and we
drove to Chattanooga to shoot a music
video and it was like two hours away I
was like [ __ ] it's like right here yeah
she's like right there yeah they got
cousins facts facts how how you know
obviously Atlanta's been wild during the
pandemic because there's been I was
there in uh January and I was like this
[ __ ] is wild like this [ __ ] was wide the
[ __ ] open [ __ ] out there but Nick
tripping how was that yeah it was uh
it was I mean because I live in LA so
it's been like The Other Extreme yeah
it's worse it was worse I had all right
well no just like it I mean I guess but
just the restrictions like I feel like
we can do [ __ ] out here you can go to a
restaurant Atlanta would open now we
went to Atlanta I was like yo where I'm
over here eating hot wings and looking
at [ __ ] right now
the strip clubs was the first thing like
they I feel like the Strip Clubs closed
for like a month and then they was like
[ __ ] that [ __ ] yeah and the food man
I'll tell you what was overrated those
magic City's hot wings I was very
disappointed what blue flame much better
okay cool I can forward that and then
there was this white strip club that
played like Nickelback that everyone
told me to go to you went to the white
wait with the pink pony yes no you can't
go there no no no no no I went to the
Pink Pony with Jaron Benton and then he
took us to this other place where there
was like [ __ ] strippers and old ladies
Claremont Lounge I never heard of that
you guys know about that you know what
that is
no but there's another club that's like
no everyone goes to to eat food that's
that's magic or blue flame like no no no
no no no no no every rapper was like you
gotta go here don't worry about the
music of the women but the food is fire
I don't know what it look like I'm
trying to remember the name of this
place but I went to the Pink Pony the
pink pony was whatever yeah that's some
like it's like a Grand Theft Auto Type
strip club yeah I went to like 12 of
them I was like the whole time that's
good we're just at the strip club all
right where we going tonight you gotta
go to the real Ratchet five dollars oh I
went to all of that listen we was we we
went to
all of them I just told I told Killer
Mike I said where do I need to go okay
you that's that's cool go here go here
and then I said and he didn't say go to
Magic City but I was like I gotta go and
then the wings were so tiny you went to
Blue Flame or Magic first uh I went to
Magic City first then I went to blue
flame blue flame is much better yeah
that's a
the food it's just a preference though
you like ratchet [ __ ] but I feel like
Magic City is like I'm just in my
Cuisine
I'll eat just the food yeah blue flames
from West sideways you gotta go can't
nobody I don't eat chicken no more by
the way I'm vegan but oh congrats I mean
I think right I don't know if that's a
good thing or not I feel bad for you I
feel it's a good thing for me I mean
good for you whatever floats your boat
man cause I got now ate too many I'm
from Atlanta you ate too much chicken
yes bro I don't need that [ __ ] any I
know what to say like yeah so do you
have like lemon pepper like
big cauliflower Wings yes I mean this
but that's cauliflower it's not Wings
just say you have lemon pepper
cauliflower don't say the word wings but
they wings no they're not bro I'm Gonna
Keep it a book like they're calling it's
cauliflower bro but look though what
about it as a wing let me ask you this
how does chicken taste like what did
like don't not the sauce I'm on keto so
I ate a lot of cauliflower in my life at
the moment certainly don't [ __ ] taste
like cauliflower but okay I'm saying
though
what folk really like to I think the
seasoning is the sauce and [ __ ] yeah I
like that chicken too I like to bite I
like I clean the bone but they got [ __ ]
there's like a texture it's the same bro
I had some it's cauliflower but all
right all right forget the Cobble out
here they got some [ __ ] I forgot what
it's called but it it feels just like
chicken like I just like I'll be going
through the [ __ ] grocery store and
they'll have like the vegan section and
it'll say vegan chicken strips I'm like
these aren't chicken strips you can't
get that [ __ ] you can't get that [ __ ]
it's not it nah what about like
impossible burgers
I follow the impossible yeah does it
taste like a burger yeah it tastes like
a matter of fact next time you go to
Atlanta go to a place called [ __ ]
vegan I've heard of [ __ ] vegan get
that [ __ ] I think they use it impossible
I asked somebody where should I go you
you should go to celebrity vegan I said
I should not go to this I'm in [ __ ]
vacation but I look like going to a
vegan restaurant you slept right you
need to go we went to uh a bunch of
spots though I felt like we was like
yeah Atlanta has some great food man
nothing like uh obviously hitting the uh
the old Waffle House at 5am as well I I
ate bro I ate so much of that [ __ ] like
I ate that [ __ ] for 24 years like I'm
straight I know it I know how it tastes
it tastes the same years huh did you
think about Waffle House is like
you should be only so lucky to have
Waffle House in your state I'm from from
Arizona so we have Waffle House La we
got no Waffle House it's just old it's
like Old Reliable you get at the club
it's three four five in the morning like
you know you could go you got somewhere
to eat yeah
awful too oh out here oh yeah yeah
California's got good Mexican food yeah
Taco just the best tacos and [ __ ] on the
head yeah uh outside of that uh like no
boost fire they got good seafood and
[ __ ] but like the chicken is getting uh
you there's a place called what's is it
called Gus's Famous Fried Chicken
yeah that [ __ ] ain't it people become yo
I gotta go to Gus's I'm like no you
don't where are you from you're from the
south don't go to Gus's because you're
gonna be disappointed man so um
damn that's crazy you got a song with
Freddie Gibbs and you never even met
this cat yeah but I I don't know I
always been a fan like you know what I'm
saying that [ __ ] was like I feel like I
just talked about him and I talked him
up let me see if I can get this
[ __ ] to answer his Facetime real
quick we'll have you meet him right now
I have feeling this shit's gonna happen
that's hard
we were just with we we just met Drake
together the other day how was how was
that
he's answering
Frederick
what are you doing buddy
oh God damn why are you always [ __ ]
going somewhere dog what what island
hey what island
I'm going to Kauai okay hey look I'm I'm
doing a podcast with this kid named
Kenny Mason you have a song with them
and he said he never met you
've never met me
well look just just uh turn your [ __ ]
camera on so you can say hi to this guy
we're we're filming right now so I'm
trying to do the introduction
all right all right
this [ __ ] is going to Hawaii
that's time just unaware
yeah like I just talked to this guy I
didn't mention I'm going away I'm like
bro he's [ __ ] it's like let's go to
Hawaii
Gangsta Gibbs you've been Hawaii yeah
Maui oh sorry now we survive you've been
there I ain't never been nowhere so go
to Maui bro that [ __ ] is uh it looked
like Hawaii out here
nah no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no I just ain't seen [ __ ] man this
[ __ ] out here sucks I ain't gonna lie I
got love from California
the beaches and [ __ ] out here are trash
you if you want to go to like a beach
bro the beach was five we just went nah
go to [ __ ]
well this Gibbs
yo
yo this guy's got the best Gmail ever
that [ __ ] crazy say hi to this guy
what's up gang what's going on
we're going on my way
I'm ready I'm in La now [ __ ] oh I came
ahead and do that [ __ ] really he said
he's ready but he's going to Hawaii so
you're gonna have to do it another time
right
all month he said
all right well have fun man in Hawaii
and uh
you know do your best to uh
I don't know don't make the shade room
while you're out there is all I'm gonna
say
just don't beat up any locals
all right I'm proud of you all right
we're gonna get back to this interview I
just wanted to he said he never met you
so
all right brother yo have to stop the
bootleg here podcast real quick and
Shout out our sponsor Odd Socks that's
right they've been holding us down from
the Jump Man and they're not only the
makers of the most comfortable socks in
the world shout out to Odd Socks but
they also now got the draws man
the boxer briefs are so fire
they're so soft they feel great on your
ass your nuts whatever you're into you
know what I'm saying whatever you got
they'll cover them up real real
comfortably and ladies you know you
could wear these things to sleep so go
to oddsoxofficial.com use the keyword
bootleg cab save 20 off you know one of
the licenses they just got that I love
uh are the Naruto socks they just got
the Naruto socks of course they got WWE
those are mankind socks ladies and
gentlemen SpongeBob and shout out to the
the goat Ric Flair so what you got to do
get you some Odd Socks Thank Me Later
save 20 off at checkout by using the
keyword bootleg Kev at
oddsoxofficial.com and we are super
proud that they're presenting this
podcast let's get back to it oh there
you go man Freddie Gibbs video hopefully
soon yeah nice you're in La all month so
you got to make it happen that's an
emotion yeah yeah yeah
um why so when you put out your Strays
like the video like like because you
know with people who look you up on
YouTube
it's like a live performance type
situation yeah if it's very original
like I haven't seen anybody do anything
like that I mean I mean obviously people
do like one takes or they'll do like
unplugged versions of their records but
like the way you did it I thought was
dope what inspired you to do that
um my homeboy DC thought of it because
he was just like
[ __ ] we can't do shows right now right
so let's just do a show and you can in
Atlanta
yeah I I wasn't doing that [ __ ] I'm just
saying but but you could I'm just saying
you could yeah I want to [ __ ] around
with them folks I would not fool around
with no Folk yeah I so she he was just
like yeah we're just gonna do a show in
this room and like the first one it
wasn't meant to be like the first one
was like
you know I'm doing like freestyles on
there and [ __ ] you know what I'm saying
I didn't think he was going to be like a
big like right people was gonna [ __ ]
with it as much as they did so but they
did
so it was just like yeah we're gonna do
another one and like actually like do it
for real like you know what I'm saying
how's like the uh you know because
you've been bubbling for a couple of
years like what what is like uh
I always talk to artists about like what
there's always you know a fork in the
road where you could either go
independent or you could sign with
somebody like where are you where's your
head at with that uh we I got them
I signed folks I signed who'd you sign
with we were RCA oh RCA shout out to RCA
good people over there I fought with it
because they've also dropped the ball on
some good artists so stay on their ass
nah what the thing with me is the way my
[ __ ] set up is like they they look like
I don't know they let me do what I want
to do you know what I'm saying that's
all that matters yeah it ain't no it's a
respect don't folk the only I they them
folk came to where I stated like they
pulled all the way to like on deal like
right hood and [ __ ] like tunji and Mark
Pitts and you know saying Russian [ __ ]
they came to my house so it was like no
they're good people yeah like respect
yeah you had the nice a nice Squad pull
up on you for sure yeah I fought with
them you know what I'm saying so it was
just like all right yeah like
cool yeah plus like you could like you
know I feel like you got the capability
to just kind of
you know be like they they're missing
what you bring to the table at RCA
uh I don't know I don't think about that
type of [ __ ] I mean look you got to
because like if you think about like
who's on RCA like they need somebody who
could be like their Kendrick they're
cold like they're like you know they're
like a rapper that brings a ton of
artistic credibility to the table that's
that's cool that's I I thought with that
they think of me like that but yeah as
they should man as they should
um what else is on the way for you I
mean obviously the album is out uh the
Angelic [ __ ] the Stray [ __ ] I mean
you're going crazy but like what is like
what do you want to like let's say the
rest of 2021 how do you want the rest of
your year to go man I want to [ __ ]
perform bro like you want to go crazy
live 100 I'm ready to go I mean a lot of
tourists are coming back in like October
you know are you are are you like
getting on any tours you're gonna do
your own some talks with a lot of people
that I respect so that's probably gonna
happen soon and also I'm on like seven
festivals so like that's that's that too
are you rolling out loud yeah oh that
should be fun yeah I'm gonna be there
have you been running loud yet in life I
did I'm rolling out of Miami 2019. oh
that was like the real [ __ ] up year
yeah [ __ ] with a big ass right and [ __ ]
oh yeah I was there yeah that was some
real yo it's crazy because I was that
was the year that Josh Jackson from the
Phoenix Suns got arrested for trying to
get backstage that's great and I was
sudsman I was like yo I heard a [ __ ]
roll allowed that year was [ __ ] just
a free it was like a rapper free for all
out there nah that [ __ ] was fine I got
them I came out my trailer and Tiana
Trump walked right by me I was like what
the [ __ ] Tiana Trump walk by what'd you
say I didn't say [ __ ]
you're a fan
yeah she's great she is great she's
great yeah no she's amazing yeah I
always tell anybody just go to go to her
Twitter she got the pin video at the top
that tells Pizza tells you exactly why
people love her right there off the rip
she's she's a legend bro she is who else
are legends in the porn game to you I
don't know like that now I don't I ain't
watch porn for real like
and since probably I was like 20 some
nice [ __ ] guys so yo Giada Trump but
I was excited now but I mean she like a
man that's like knowing who got them I
don't know if you um
that's like knowing Guy Fieri if you
don't know chefs but you know you know
so you know that and you're like so
you're saying the only porn star you
know is Tiana Trump ah so who else
um
I can't well if you if you saying you
say a name and I'll be like okay
I know that so now you're putting it on
me to be there because I can't think of
nothing I can't think of like
we can go down the list I know I guess
if they face I see their face and be
like oh they that's a porn star yeah
Pinky Okay yeah okay see I wouldn't even
thought of her but that's some old [ __ ]
ain't it that's something like yeah she
was like a [ __ ] that was like the
2000s she was like a fat little [ __ ]
chick
nah nah none and I met her in person at
the avns she's a short little lady man
she's that's why she she was so thick
because she was like stubby
shout out shout out to pinky man she a
legend man well like uh pluck plug your
[ __ ] and uh we're gonna have You
Freestyle man in a little bit so there's
gonna be a different YouTube video we
can watch this guy do what he does best
but tell everybody what you got going on
before you get off the podcast man uh
yeah you can follow me everywhere at
Kenny Mason
k-e-n-n-y-m-a-s-o-n oh extra [ __ ] J
Kenny Mason
taking the Hawks over the Knicks in the
playoffs uh yeah all right there you go
that four or five seed going down man
trade a